this week on quadriga Iran deal all
about business the Iran nuclear deal is
just a few days old and German economics
Minister Zig Magana is already in Tehran
discussing business prospects with the
regime the declared aim of the nuclear
talks was to prevent Iran from getting
the bomb and to make the Middle East
safe ER but did the West have an
ulterior motive is the deal with Iran
all about business coming to you from
Berlin quad Riga the international
debate your host this week john barrack
welcome to quad riga a deal has been
struck and already approved by the UN
and europe our new old trading partner
Iran a country notorious for supporting
terrorist groups such as Hezbollah and
Hamas for trampling on the rights of its
own citizens and for vowing repeatedly
to wipe Israel off the map coming out of
this deal the big winners appear to be
international banks and big corporations
so is this deal all about business
my guests today first of all adnan tap
attacked by an Iranian political
scientist based in Berlin he says
diplomacy works this nuclear agreement
is a blueprint for conflict resolution
in the Middle East and Alan Posner
British porn journalist who writes for
the German newspaper Die Welt
he says the mullahs are the problem not
the bomb they exploited our weakness to
get a deal that benefits them without
giving us anything in return and odel
Abidin felt well-known german economics
writer and journalist she says iran is
not a friend Iran remains dangerous but
it's better to try a deal than to risk a
war
allan poe's now let me put the first
question to you 12 years of negotiations
and then this germany has played a
significant role in brokering this deal
we are told you don't think much of the
deal do you well no because basically we
had we since 2006 we've had your UN
Security Council resolution saying Iran
must irrevocably give up all its nuclear
ambitions including especially
everything to do with preparing and and
enriching uranium and they haven't done
that it's been mothballed but even not
all of the program has been mothballed a
third of the the things they use these
or losing the word now I still in place
thank you so much
and and and so and they hadn't made any
concessions on any other issues which
you which you talked about human rights
and under the attitude towards Israel
man human rights at your doors is due to
all their neighbors in fact the
expansionist nature of the regime so
basically we haven't got anything
politically in return but obviously and
also as you pointed out the Germans are
eager to deals with them not only the
Germans but especially the Germans well
as we saw the two the German economics
minister and Vice Chancellor was there
before they the Inc had dried on the
paper in fact the ink hasn't even been
signed yet because it hasn't been
ratified by the Iranians yet it hasn't
been ratified it has been ratified by
the United States Congress either so
they're they're already there and of
course the reason is oil well earth
Allah Biden felt Benjamin not Netanyahu
the Israeli prime minister told the
Knesset the Israeli Parliament this
agreement does not make war more distant
it brings war closer he's presumably
thinking of the fact that in his view at
least Israel feels isolated and
abandoned and that therefore a military
strike against Iran is once again on the
table
well I don't think that he's right
because what what we have is not a new
thing of agreement of friendship or of
whatever it is only about preventing war
from the Near East and it is and and it
is probably the first agreement which
came to an a good and it's not an end
yet but it has some some perspectives of
often good and with in between Iran and
the US and I think that this is one of
the the most important things given the
experiences we made the last years in
Syria in Iraq in Afghanistan which were
all conflicts which didn't come to to an
end at all so I think that this is one
of problem perhaps one of the first
steps to come to two agreements which do
not and inevitably in no in a war
between the u.s. the NATO Europe and one
of the countries in this area the German
Foreign Minister frank-walter Steinmeier
says himself this agreement is not based
on trust
he says fairly openly we don't trust
Iran we're going to monitor it very
closely but we've been doing this for
years
it can't be trust in between Iran and
any of the countries the agreement is
about so it has to be controlled and
probably you are right when you say well
the control thing is not as evolved and
developed as it should be but it is not
not trust it's not friendship it is
mistrust and it is there they are not
friends they don't become friends in the
next 10 or 20 years so you think the
monitoring now is going to be different
from the monitoring before yes I think
because there is an agreement there is
the first step to be on speaking terms
again and that is quite historical in
terms of if you just only look at the
the relationships between the u.s. and
Iran Iran before adnan tabata by
Iran is a burgeoning economy isn't it I
mean it's the third largest economy in
the region when I look at the Iranian
press they don't talk about any of these
foreign policy issues that I mentioned
in the beginning of the program I get
the impression that the Iranians don't
see this as being any kind of backing
down on foreign policy issues on human
rights issues even perhaps on their
nuclear program they see it very much in
business terms don't there well I think
economic aspirations may have been the
main incentive to be or just for a well
I mean we're not speaking about Iran
obviously economic interests are always
the best accelerator to any process but
for in for the Iranian case they know
very well that as long as they do not
improve the economic situation inside
the country this this country will also
lose its stability in every regard so
that's obviously a main incentive so
getting sanctions relief or the release
of frozen assets to boost the economy at
home is obviously a main goal and
therefore this this was one aspect that
was the most important for the Iranian
team and when it comes to you mentioned
the issue of trust for Iran it was about
okay we we make our nuclear program more
transparent and therefore we ask for
sanctions relief because you will then
see that we have nothing to hide and
then obviously the extent of
transparency on the one hand and the
extent of sanctions relief on the other
hand is something that you have to do to
do bargain and verification mechanisms
on both sides must compensate the utter
lack of trust that exists on the table
president obama is already basking in
the anticipated glory of a major foreign
policy achievement
and the international banks and large
corporations particularly here in Europe
are hardly able to concealer the light
at this deal here are some of the
arguments of the people who believe that
this was an historic breakthrough the
nuclear deal is the right move because
Iran has now finally made a commitment
to only use the technology for purely
civilian purposes and agreed to
international monitoring of its atomic
program that makes both the region and
the world a safer place the nuclear deal
is the right move because cultural
traditions have shaped Iran for
thousands of years it has many
well-educated young people and it's not
wise to cut the country off from the
world community long-term cultural
exchange will make change they're more
likely the nuclear deal is the right
move because the West needs Iran as an
ally in the battle against Islamic state
is continues to pose the biggest
challenge to peace and stability in the
region
Ananta bye
we talked about oil with Iran obviously
that's terribly important we talked
about trade I'd like to concentrate on
something else these hundred billion or
so dollars that are sitting around
frozen in accounts what's going to
happen to the money as I mentioned
earlier Iran is really has to boost its
own economy and I know where you're
coming from because the questions always
will this money go directly into weapons
for militias electrons cetera but the
one thing that is really important here
is that those elements inside the
political establishment of Iran who have
the finances to to fund such groups have
their very own institutions that are
completely independent from state
revenues they have foundations and other
institutions that are very well funded
and they don't need additional money the
the money that is really necessary at
the moment is to increase the capacities
of Iran's industry to have a job market
which is responsive build up the
infrastructure that's what Iran itself
says the money obviously I mean there is
a lot of potential for example for it
for for tourism and a lot has to be put
into the building tankers for example
again you need other tankers don't they
when they increase their oil supply the
the fleet is pretty pretty old now
exactly I mean the the anything starting
from the centrifuges that are from the
70s to the tankers and and and the
trucks that you would see on the roads
it's really 3040 years year old cars and
the money that sounds pretty good to
German business doesn't it it does and
what the amazing thing is who if you're
having such a problem with your
infrastructure why build an atomic
program like this you're sitting on the
third biggest oil reserves in the world
the biggest natural gas reserves
you don't need atomic energy but they
put all their money into that at the
risk of their own kind of getting
sanctions and of their own population
bring under them the population has
suffered under them the regime is
weakened due to that and now we're
handing the money on the plate without
demanding that they really take down
their atomic capacity and how can you
say they're not taking it down 95%
reduction of plutonium only 1/3 or
centrifuges left automation they need
that for what do they need plutonium for
if not to build bombs
no one needs boots on you except for
anything else with building bombs it's
enough to have one bomb detonate in Tel
Aviv and and you'll have changed the
history of the of the of the Near East
forever so so this is the whole the
whole point they only need one bomb and
they've still got that capacity and
quite frankly you know this this this
this race to to give them money to
strike deals is not only to give them
money to earn money well the third
largest economy in the Middle East yes
they're going to be buying for example
German ships German firstly it is all
about the peace but not to have another
war in the region and secondly it is
about business from both both sides so I
think we have to put the things in the
right order it is not all about business
how can you say it's about not having
another war in the region when we have a
war in Syria we have a war in Yemen we
have Hezbollah do you recommend a war
between Iran and Israel or between Iran
and the earth this is ridiculous I even
felt you say yourself you don't trust
the Iranian government but you have some
faith presumably in the new monitoring
system the term that's being bandied
about at the moment is snapback
sanctions isn't it that if they don't
fulfill the conditions the sanctions are
going to snap back but if for example
European businesses start investing
billions into Iran together you know it
could well amount to billions short is
going to be enormous pressure on on
governments from big corporations and
banks were
financing the new trade not to impose
those sanctions reintroduce their
sanctions well I think it is it is
becoming more difficult of course but I
think that especially at the US
especially in Germany and in Europe
there's one thing which would stop
everything and that is the security of
Israel so I think that you are right the
temptations are there and there is moral
hazard all round but is it is it better
to risk a war Iran is officially
involved with Israel with Israel in in
in the area between the wars in the area
Iran is not involved right now isn't it
unofficially though it's probably
cooperating with America who is not
exactly
I mean Islamic state this is this is a
point this is a point do you think Allen
that that perhaps mr. Obama's enthusiasm
for the lifting of sanctions and better
relationship with with Iran is the fact
that he can't put boots on the ground
against is but that Iran would be
prepared to do that well that may be one
factor but you have to understand where
is is coming from is is base in Syria
and Iraq and these are two countries
which are both allied with Iran and
where the Sunni majority population has
been alienated by a Shia minority
government which is basically a stood
them from any stake in the country which
is why they are flocking towards is as
the only organization who stands up for
them so in their way Iran is responsible
for that too now to come and say oh
there there say there are Savior in in
in in you know by by fighting against is
is is is paranoid quite frankly
schizophrenic but I mean thinking about
how I will come back to any question
that you have I mean thinking is
speaking of is and basically our Isis
and and thinking that Iran is basically
the starting point or Iran's involvement
in those countries how can we not speak
about the
of the military invasion of the United
States and in Britain in Iraq how can we
not speak about the utterly poor
management of the situation in the
country after this after this invasion I
mean there are lots of actors as I
mentioned earlier who created this mess
and we would need all these actors to
come together and basically clean it up
and therefore you will have to talk even
to those whom you do not personally like
and that's probably what the US is doing
at least we hear that they're doing that
now behind the scenes plans they'll be
able to do it in future
officially I want to ask you about
something else so you mentioned this
yourself or implied it we talked about
problems in the in the Iranian economy
but in fact there's a young prosperous
well-educated generation that's emerging
in Iran does this deal bring the hope of
regime change coming from that corner or
at least reform I mean the important
thing is that like in any other country
these people hope that their government
gradually becomes more responsive to
their demands and if you talk to people
in Iran and I am regularly there they
have the hope that things will gradually
change and they know that there is no
way but gradual change to improve the
situation revolution or any form of
things that we saw in the so-called Arab
Eleonora looped Arab Spring is really no
option for it for the Iranians I talked
to and for for many Iranians who
participated in the elections so they
know that gradually things can improve
and better diplomatic relations to other
world powers were a lesson that will
lessen the tensions of Iran with other
countries and less tangents
automatically lead to less repression at
home this is what we saw in the end 90s
early 2000s things got really worse with
the Bush era with the Ahmadinejad era
and this is the hope that people have
and absolutely yes there is this hope
that this deal will have its
trickle-down effect in the country as
well gradually slowly but a solid
towards better time Iran demands
Israel's denies Israel's right to exist
it's repeatedly vowed to to wipe Israel
off the map
more than any other nation Germany feels
a responsibility for Israel's security
that's because this country murdered six
million Jews and it this responsibility
for Israel's security has been a
cornerstone of German foreign policy
with every government since the Second
World War
either thoughts aforethought Germany's
historic responsibility is part of my
country's reason of state this means
that for me as German Chancellor
Israel's security will never be
negotiable German policy is determined
by its advocacy for Israel's security
and its right to exist
Israel needs to be allowed to live in
peace with guaranteed borders you have
to understand that for us Germans
ensuring that Israel's security needs
are not called into question is of
ongoing significance
Vaslav I'd inferred we don't have much
time unfortunately for this very complex
question but Germany played a
significant role in brokering this deal
the Israeli government feels betrayed
quite clearly is it not a betrayal I
don't think it is a betrayal because I
think that the they cook everybody who
negotiated this agreement and everybody
who was involved in the the process
before has won is deeply convinced but
the security of Israel is is to be
granted and that is that this is not to
be negotiated and therefore I think it
is one way to look for more peace for
Less conflict in the region it might
work out but it might not it might not
but it is only one way it is not a
fundamental betrayal on
Germany's responsibilities to Israel's
security Alan Posner we heard in that
little report this term reason of state
at the technical term of course but very
loosely I suppose we should could
explain some of our viewers who don't
perhaps understand it that it means an
absolute priority that takes precedence
over all moral concerns in fact and
Chancellor Merkel and every German
Chancellor for a long time has said that
this is so when the Vice Chancellor John
Vice Chancellor was in Tehran this week
he said for us Germans Israel's security
needs are of ongoing significance is
that backtracking
it's obviously backtracking and it's
already what he says it's what they're
doing it's not only Israel it's you know
they it's it's the Arab states the
so-called moderate abidor Arab states
Saudi Arabia the Gulf states Yemen other
states who've stood by us all this time
and who weren't even consulted before
this deal was done with the arraigns no
one asked any of them what they felt
about it and they're deeply concerned so
we are backtracking on on positions and
we are with we're we're betraying people
who've stood by us through the whole
Cold War
who stood by her through the what were
the the the the the the the to Iraq was
which we've had since then who stood by
America and the West and now weren't
even consulted before this deal was
struck and I think that's disgraceful
man finally the Ayatollah Khamenei the
Supreme Leader of Iran in a mosque last
weekend preached a sermon in which he
said this deal is not going to have any
effect on on Iran's foreign policy and
the worshippers chanted death to America
death to Israel do you think that this
is just a minority in in Iran who feel
this way is is this going to change I
mean the this agreement was only
possible because they've really focused
on Iran's nuclear program and didn't
discuss anything else I think it is also
true that Iran's main principles in its
foreign policy or in this position
towards the United States or its views
of Israel will not change I do believe
that cooperation on some security issues
with with the United States as has
already been happening will also be
happening the radical positions against
the United States and Israel I strongly
believe is a minority position in Iran
it's a very vocal minority but it's also
a politically not so effective minority
they feel the discursive realm they have
the microphones they have the papers
they have the the mosque to speak and
you have the impression that this is
everywhere but basically the decision
makers think in much more pragmatic
terms which is why I while I do not
really like this kind of chance I am not
really scared or worried about them
because this is something that is going
on like a ritual and as unpleasant as it
sounds I don't see it really being
something that runs against this nuclear
agreement right we only have time not
very quickly unfortunately I can see see
we still have lots that we could discuss
but we're a quick round I'm going to
pose the question that we began this
this this show with the question is this
ultimately the steal all about business
those'll of Isis
is not and I think there can't be any
doubt that anybody in Germany and in
Europe and in the u.s. puts Israel at
risk or a tax at a saturation which
would lead our to more insecurity in
Israel at non economic incentives helped
but this was about proving that
diplomacy can reach something and I
think this is a major achievement and
finally Alan Posner unfortunate not only
about business if it was that be it'll
be okay it's about a total romantic idea
of achieving peace in the Middle East
without being strong and that's not
gonna happen
thank you very much all of you for being
my guest thank you very much for
watching join us again next week on
quadriga
you